hey guys how's it going so I just got
I'm watching the Apple announcement and
if you guys were following my tweets you
might know how I sort of felt about it
and obviously it was a smaller
announcement and I still had high hopes
that they were going to make some
announcement with the iPhone 7 as
everyone has been telling me they're
like no Justine it's not gonna happen
and guess what it didn't happen but what
they did announce is a new iPad pro a
new iPhone se which is a 4-inch iPhone
which I think we already pretty much
knew this two months ago they also
announced some new Apple watch bands and
they dropped the price of the Apple
watch to $2.99 and Tim Cook of course
kicked off the event talking about the
whole Apple security and the government
and then they talked about how Apple is
doing all of these amazing things for
the environment which is great really
exciting but they spent half of the
keynote talking about those things and
and it was a really short event and they
only talked about the Apple watch for
two seconds let's just go through
we're checking out Mac rumors MacRumors
has been one of my favorite sites pretty
much honestly since I can even remember
I've been going to this website forever
so it's usually my number one go-to for
any news I was following their coverage
while I was watching the actual live
stream you guys didn't watch the event
here's what we're gonna go through so
they started off the event with sort of
a kind of a cool little mashup video of
a little celebration of Apple turning 40
on April 1st so it was a 40 second video
of Apple's 40th birthday so they went
through all these cool things except it
was only text I could have done
something so incredible with trying to
recap 40 years of Apple in 40 seconds
hopefully they'll have something really
cool for us on April 1st because it
really really could have been something
awesome that they could have done with
that I'm really tired
I'm not gonna lie I just got back from
Miami so Tim was talking about the
ongoing FBI ordeal that's going on with
the government he said it is important
for Americans to join the conversation
and Apple is grateful for the
overwhelming support that has received
from customers around the world and it's
not only customers they are also getting
so much amazing feedback from bigger
companies who are also supporting their
decision so that's what Tim let it off
with and then they went into talking
about the environment
one of the cool things they talked about
is Liam is this little guy right here
and they showed how he deconstructs the
iPhones when you turn them into their
recycling program I tweeted that a hotel
thing that there is going to be a Liam
consumer version that they could come
and help me recycle things in my house
and clean my house for me so Apple you
might want to consider that next up they
started talking about care kit and this
is a framework for developers to build
apps that empower people to take an
active role in their care so basically
what that means is they're releasing a
developer kit that will allow people to
create applications on top of iOS to
help create apps for the healthcare
community they also showed a really cool
video that kind of showed how people are
using these applications and how it's
changing the healthcare as we know it
one of the things that I've been looking
forward to this entire announcement was
the announcement of some new Apple watch
bands so here they are I'm not sure if
this pink is a new color but I think it
is and it's pretty beautiful the woven
nylon ones are the pretty much where the
highlight of the announcement they come
in the gold red got a royal blue pink
love it pearl scuba blue and black woven
nylon they also have now a black version
of the millenia sloop and this is
probably one of my favorite watch bands
ever it really gets perfect it's
lightweight and it just kind of fold
over very nicely and it's very
comfortable to wear on a day to day
basis I'm actually wearing a third party
Apple watch band this is the first one
that I've ever even sort of investigated
and my friend got me this for my
birthday and it's a rose gold so it
matches sort of the rose gold aluminum
face pretty perfectly so I've been
wearing that and I love it
I've yet to really sort of get into any
the third party watch bands if you guys
have any recommendations but you leave
those in the comments because I would
like to check those out so those are
some of the new Apple watch band I like
that they finally have the link
bracelets available to purchase except
that's really expensive for a watch band
to beginning today they also drop the
price to $2.99 for Apple watches and
that was really it let's look at the
time that Tim came on stage ten twenty
five ten twenty seven it will
literally two minutes of Apple watch huh
Apple TV was up next ran through some of
the new features so it looks like
there's dictation Siri for App Store
iCloud photo sharing live photos folders
then what we've all been waiting for is
Apple introducing the new iPhone se it
looks just like the iPhone 5 but with
the introduction of the new rose gold
which looks fantastic that's 12
megapixel iSight camera true tone flash
which is the dual flash that will kind
of adjust to different lighting which is
pretty important if you ask me if you're
taking pictures of any flashes
incredible battery improvements LTE's
faster Wi-Fi calling blue to the iPhone
se pricing starts at 399 for the 16
gigabyte so basically this new small
tiny iPhone se is quite powerful but
here's what I'm asking you guys do you
want a smaller iPhone because once you
actually use a bigger phone and then you
go back to using one of the smaller ones
I can't see it so let me know in the
comments below what you guys think about
Apple announcing a smaller phone not
only did they announce a smaller phone
they also announced a smaller iPad so
what I feel like the trend is at this
whole entire event was guys guess what
do you remember when we made all of
these big things big things like the
massive iPad and your massive phone we
think you might want something a little
bit smaller so let's go back and they
went back so we've got a smaller phone
we've also got a smaller iPad pro which
is up next but one of the things that I
do like about the new iOS 9 3 feature is
the night shift there's a really great
chance that before bed you are on your
phone and they have been doing studies
that shows that a blue light actually
makes you have a trouble falling asleep
so people that may have trouble falling
asleep it could be because you're on
your phone before you're going to sleep
so because of the lighting studies they
do offer this feature night shift so it
can tell that when the Sun is actually
starting to set in whatever time zone
you happen
bein with your iphone lighting on your
iOS device will adjust to be a little
bit warmer iOS 93 is actually available
for everyone beginning today so that's
quite exciting I've already started
refreshing my phone to see if it's
working and let's see not out yet so
Phil Schiller is now on stage he's
chatting about the nine point seven inch
iPad pro I've also have sold over 200
million 9.7 iPads today cool what's
because it's it really actually is the
perfect size like this is perfect this
is a computer although I'm not gonna lie
this is a really fantastic device I do
love the iPad pro I wish I was a better
illustrator I am NOT what it is pretty
awesome to be able to just be able to
draw on your device that being said this
is a video all about Apple but I've
recently got a Microsoft Surface book
and it's everything that Apple should
have done it kind of actually breaks my
heart a little bit to say it it's a
tablet when you want it to be a tablet
it's a computer when you want it to be a
computer one of the things that Apple
said in this event it felt like they
were really attacking the PC market they
were wanting the new iPad pros to
replace your old PCs here's the problem
I have with that iPad and iOS could
potentially be a replacement for most
people but for everyone
I don't think it can be yet it's not a
full operating system I can't run the
things that I want to run on it that I
run on OS X when it could potentially be
fast enough what the OS is still
simplified well the Microsoft Surface is
done is absolutely incredible because it
is a laptop it is a full-featured power
laptop that you can actually detach the
device and it'll downgrade the tablet so
that we'll be able to adjust for battery
settings and italy turn that into a
tablet attach it back to your computer
it turns it back into the computer it
drives me insane that Apple has not made
a touchscreen laptop yet I realize you
want us to buy the
has put all what man all I freaking want
come here baby tell them all oh boy
that's not my dog anyway I still love
Apple they have my heart but some things
just really want to get me fired so
going on chiller says 600 million pcs in
news today that over five years old
these people could really benefit from
an iPad pro I sometimes need to take a
step back because I know that I am not
the average consumer for most people all
they're doing is email surfing the web I
am sort of the super computer user and I
want it to be the best and I want to be
the fastest I wanted to do absolutely
everything most people do not need that
most of those people that do have
computers that are five years old a
freaking iPad could be potentially just
perfect so what you can do is because
this has sort of the smart connectors is
you have the keyboard and you just
attach this just like so and you
instantly have pretty much a
full-featured keyboard and next up I'm
quite excited about this so this is a
USB camera adapter and an SD card reader
so this will allow you to add a USB port
to your iPad pro he mentioned for people
who are doing podcasts you'll be able to
podcast directly from your iPad pro
honestly it comes down to like what are
you guys looking for what do you need
what do you need this device for are you
doing editing are you doing photo
processing I mean I think it is powerful
enough but I think the one thing that is
really driving me crazy is the fact that
I still cannot update a thumbnail on an
iOS device for YouTube that's seriously
should we just I'm not sure whose issue
this is is it YouTube is it Google is it
Apple driving me crazy for like 10 years
tens 97th maybe six years along enough
time for it to be an issue that should
have been resolved so here's the price
points of the new iPad iPad Mini 269
iPad
to 399 iPad pro 590 they should probably
just get rid of the iPad air 2 because
there's seriously no reason to even have
that anymore I've had Pro 9 7-inch the
iPad pro 12 point 9 inch Tim also closed
the event saying that this is probably
the last product introduction in the
town hall ever because they are going to
be moving their campus somewhere else
and that's it it was only an hour long
I was hoping for one more thing there
wasn't one more thing so that's all I've
got for you let me know what you guys
think of some of the things that Apple
announced today I know it wasn't a huge
announcement one thing that would have
made this announcement really impressive
was if they would have announced
something that we didn't actually
already know I mean pretty much
everything that they talked about was
things that have already been leaked in
the past couple of months I'm looking
forward to WWDC hopefully they'll make
some announcements on the iPhone 7 and
also potentially something in the VR
space because Apple is really falling
behind publicly in the virtual reality
space because we don't know anything so
hopefully that's something that they're
just keeping super-secret because that
would be great to have some
announcements to see if they can sort of
compete with every other VR headset and
company that has kind of been popping up
in the past five years so that's that
let me know all of your thoughts in the
comments below and I will see you guys
in my next video
look at baby boy Baker in the back seats
John took Maddy I took Baker and we
didn't want them to be the car together
because we weren't sure how the
interaction would